this is a world of movie remakes is only
a matter of time before Robocop got his
Robocop robot so Robocop is a remake of
the 1980s movie Robocop this one has a
bit of a different spin although it does
have the same elements as the first one
but a different spin it's a story of
Murphy he's a guy he's a good cop he
gets wasted and a car bomb this time
because this is a pg-13 movie Michael
Keaton's like let's make him a robot
Michael Keaton's in this movie he owns
this company has a lot of drones over in
the Middle East they're all keeping the
peace everything's all fine and dandy
it's all fine and dandy not because
there's a lot of peace but because the
beginning of this movie reminds me so
much Metal Gear Solid 4 but the people
of America don't want drones running
their streets they want police officers
they want heart so Keaton's like alright
let's make a cyborg that'll get people
on our side little bit like the Borg
Meets police officers what's not to get
behind anyhow now Murphy is Robocop I
actually enjoyed this movie I thought I
was gonna all over this movie I was
like alright let's tear it apart as good
action I liked Murphy the kaabah me the
actress functional in the movie he's not
blow my socks off I'm not like I need to
see the guy played Robocop and more
I'm saying for playing Robocop II was
pretty good this suit didn't piss me off
at first he has a suit that's like the
old-school Robocop suit and like I let's
give him a really sleek black suit the
trailer and the pictures of the suit
didn't do it justice cuz he looks really
small he look like he had my frame I'm
like that's not menacing you see the
skinny black suit dude coming after
you're like what are you ninja cop but
in the movie he actually still looked
enormous he looks like a big dudes
alright props to the suit this who's not
bad I like the way he walked - he walks
mechanical is all like was awesome
he just he looked heavy this movie does
a different take we're in the old
Robocop he's just scrubbed completely
doesn't remember who he was the movies
about him regaining his humanity this
one he wakes up and he still remembers
that he is the cop Murphy and he's like
what the hell did you do to me and then
he goes through a lot of rigorous
training and they're doing tweaks on him
he's coming to terms with what he is and
then later on in the movie they scrub
him anyway and make him Robocop that you
remember where he has no real
personality and after that it's all
about him regaining his humanity the
scenarios are he wakes up he doesn't
remember who he is he has no personality
now he's Robocop or he wakes up he
remembers who he is he tries to come to
terms with it and then later on in the
movie you scrub him anyway
now he's Robocop what's the difference
about a half an hour yeah granted you
got to see some cool training and you
get a lot of screen time with Gary
Oldman I think that's why they did it
cuz it like we paid for Gary Oldman
we're gonna have Gary Oldman in the
movie as much as possible so as long as
they keep all that stuff in there Gary
opens in the movie as much as possible
Brandon I like seeing him in movies Gary
Oldman who doesn't like seeing Gary
Oldman in a movie I'm just saying that
whole half an hour they used to tell
that story that they ended up blotting
away anyway could have been a half an
hour we see Robocop kicking ass I guess
it adds to the humanity of them seeing
the humanity there and then go where
right whatever had cool effects although
there were a couple of green screen
effects where I was like I can see the
green screen line around Gary Oldman's
head that's not good this movie because
what a Tilly in Hollywood dollars
you can't do that better - Robocop isn't
perfect it has its flaws for sure but it
is a lot better than I thought it was
going to be and in the end I walked out
of the movie going that was a cool
Robocop move it it feels a bit long
because it slows down after he first
becomes Robocop but in the end I will
say Robocop is still a good time no
alcohol required
it's a Robocop have you seen it what did
you think about it whatever you thought
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
you